де наші знову слуги народа де вони всі
тут же була така кількість слуг народа і
тут залишилися знову сколько 30-40 людей
скільки внут буде до завершення
працювати вже більше не треба А в
місцевих громадах люди працюють і не
можна взяти і забрати в місцевих громад
кошти і це абсолютно блюзнірський вибір
який ви ставите типу А давайте заберемо
в громад щоб дати армії ні ви заберіть в
офіса президента ви заберіть в
телемарафона ви заберіть в своїх
безкінечних серіалах 95-го Квартала ви
заберіть у Олександра Семеновича
Зеленського довічну стипендію і дайте
армії а в місцевого самоврядування і в
громад Нічого Не забирайте і тому що так
не можна робити це нищення
децентралізації І за це ганьба абсолютно